c'est une image inhabituelle un paysage
désolé plein de vase
les algues ossian colonisé le plan d'eau
du centre d'avir ans marcel baratta et
le niveau de la rivière est au plus bas
impossible dans ces conditions de
pratiquer l'aviron
la sanction est affiché un peu plus loin
le camping municipal d'oliver et compte
quarante six emplacements et affiche
complet
habituellement on fait les départs de
canaux ici on a supprimé l'activité il
ya un mois du fait du faible débit d'eau
et quitte à bord d'une prestation on
veut vendre une prestation de qualité
donc on a anticipé le lard et des canaux
et parce que c'était pas c'était pas
faisable enfin c'était pas de qualité
donc comme vous pouvez voir il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'eau dans le loiret et encore
moins dans la nuit qui est lui limite
une piste cyclable maintenant puisque
et absolument plus d'eau en amont du
loiret c'est pas une grosse activité
financière cwi une perte de service
effective pour pour le plus pour le
camping sous le porto 10 v des pêcheurs
essaient de se frayer un chemin au
milieu des algues qui ici aussi ont
proliféré
désormais ils devront renoncer à leur
friture j'ai signé ce matin s'est arrêté
qui donc interdit la pêche la
consommation des poissons et un certain
type de navigation notamment de
plaisance canoë kayak sur le loir nous
allons vérifier l'évolution de la
situation et de cette bactérie dans les
plans d'eau et nous prendrons les
mesures adéquates au moment où il le
faudra les pêcheurs en ont vu d'autres
la loire est capricieuse à moins d'un
mètre au dessous de son niveau habituel
ce n'est pas non plus la fin du monde